episode 17 so this week we're doing a
special the legendary Gary Vaynerchuk
has dropped in to say hello hello and
what brings you to London okay so I'm on
my book tour I have a book called
askgaryvee so I'm on tour
we're on the verge of officially opening
our London office some roll with Eric
and rice and the crew so taking business
meetings today's really all business
kind of day and then tomorrow I'm a book
event and yesterday was in Dublin and
off to Los Angeles which was a nice
little schlep from London yeah on
Thursday morning so just coming through
just bill itself with Southwest as well
yep just gave a keynote at South by
Southwest that was like one day one day
when it's all over I'll be home Saturday
morning actually Miami but you know some
of the family this is the phone yes good
so I was in New York a couple of weeks
ago as we guessed about on the last
episode and I had the opportunity to go
in to meet the team yes and explained to
me I'd heard of Boehner yep in the US we
have I think people understood it as a
social shop we yes started out I do
percent but I was really impressed with
the team that I met there and obviously
the London team that you've got here
because the the scope is broadened yeah
a lot and so what it as a proposition to
London there was an agency what are you
bringing here you know I think you know
in our core were were reverse engineers
who care about attention and then trying
to tell the proper story to create a
result once you have that attention yeah
so you know I you know I think currently
and you can see with the kind of body
language that I bring to this statement
currently we're positioned as a social
first digital shop I mean at the end of
the day we want to execute strategies
and creative execution and pain
amplification in places that we think
actually help whomever we work with
whether that's a non-profit trying to
raise money or that's a sporting team
trying to sell tickets whether that's a
you know beverage trying to sell in
vending machines and see stores in Tesco
we want to help people spend their money
in a place
we think is a valuable place to spend
their money and there are so many places
that we think clients are spending that
are not as valuable yeah
whether that be programmatic banner
whether that be television we think that
there's some places that just
instinctively know you can't you're
analyzing it's a nothing it's
instinctively at first yeah and then
it's normally proven through actual
sales you know I come from a retail
background so as I've gotten into the
agency and creative world I've found
that I have a very big advantage because
my instincts are to actually sell
something yeah and that helps versus
headlines and awards and reporting yeah
and just basic media metrics you know
but just buying really you can't bridge
Reisinger these are that so you're
people are obsessed with with yeah we
don't debate the quality of an
impression and so yeah I mean as I've
become educated over the last seven
years but more specifically last five on
what we're doing here but you know who
those characters are although these
these kind of names I've become
fascinated by the lack of practicality
and practitioner ship in the collective
agency and client side now by the way
there's plenty of things that people do
that for example I believe in real life
activations I believe if done right it's
incredible to activate at Bonnaroo or
Coachella or the world come I think
there's a lot of places to get attention
not just digital and I think the places
I'm obsessed with whether it's Facebook
or Instagram or snapchat in five years
will be disrupted as well yeah but I
like day-trading attention I like doing
it for the moment when Seinfeld's the
number one show on television you buy
commercials on it yeah so I don't care
where snapchat are and so remember going
I care that they're under priced right
now yeah and you are you we referred in
last week's episode to you as being as I
was saying earlier it's being part of
this disruption is that something you're
very conscious of it are you talking
about the needs and the desire for
vaynermedia to be disruptive because it
is going to disrupt the traditional
agency model like you're growing here
phenomenally far
I think when people you know I think
when people and look I'm thankful that
you know I was smiling when you said you
had heard of us in the u.s. I was
thankful because you know outside of a
couple of adage references I've been
very quiet I don't think I don't think
people really realize the scope of you
know what's 650 employees and a hundred
million dollar run revenue run rate
business we're big company and much
bigger than most people in advertising
world think of us or NOAA says you know
I've said this a lot I don't think I'm
disruptive I actually think I'm
practical I think the market is
disruptive I think I think when you're
for example we have a lot of clients and
you may as well in others do that try to
sell to people that are under 25 years
old I think running television
commercials is disruptive for a 22 year
old to buy your bubble gum or your
sneakers yeah so I I think I'm quite
practical I recognize why people think
we're disruptive I do think that we have
the potential to change the conversation
I do think that we are not passionate
about media metrics or awards or
headlines the way a lot of our
contemporaries are I have empathy for
why people have been because that's how
they get business that's not how we get
business and it's and we get business in
a very funny way we get business because
I get us business from my history of
selling stuff and people knowing it
intimately not what they read in Fast
Company and then our results you know
when we gross our patches business
through the roof when we grow a lot of
our ABI clients business when we
actually grow our bit most of my
business right now is word-of-mouth of
brand managers and CMOS going to other
places and desperately wanting to bring
us along because we did something yeah I
asked this question to Eric and Jeff and
the team in New Yorker they are the big
agencies reacting in a bad way to that
because you must be stealing I
understand what we're taking scope I
still I still think that the big
agencies as your firm are putting us in
two buckets one
oh that's just little social it doesn't
mean anything and oh that's just Gary
he's one of these [ __ ] gurus and
there's probably a bunch of interns that
he's paying no money
- they just don't look under the hood
yeah in the same way that they read
headlines on PR week and make their
assumptions on snapchat and Facebook I
think they're doing the same thing with
me that's a nice way to operate I'd
rather be like that yeah I mean look
that's the mark Endor estimated oh then
you can over deliver if you if you go
look and it's fun to have Rebecca here
you know who handles our comms if you go
look at how much has been communicated
about me as a human versus the agency in
the last 24 months it's 90 percent me
surprised because you're so sure and you
know it's funny
one could say it's narcissistic it's ego
it's things of that nature to me it's
been quite calculated like I've enjoyed
people being naive and under estimating
what we're doing to the market I have no
problem surprising people look if
they've been respecting it or if they've
been naive to it it would have been
regardless because we're gonna execute
we know how to sell stuff and at the end
of the day the Unilever is and the
proctors and the cokes and the Pepsi's
and the BMWs they care about selling at
the end of day somewhere maybe not your
brand manager maybe not the CMO that
needs a headline to get the next CMO job
but somewhere somewhere somebody cares
and the ironic thing is usually somebody
that's important yeah yeah
okay so Veda coming in July yes
you weren't the Masters of media I was
fact so I hear first off that you scored
the highest of all presenters is that
true
that makes sense I'm a big-time speaker
I also heard it for fear they said no
that's true I don't like I don't like to
speak for free but promised my wife it's
it went down very well so what that
wasn't that was a new thing was it going
to speak to the market is it that kind
of it's fixed I'm starting to cut me
look I'm doing this show I'm starting to
come out into this world and it's going
well because honestly look and I already
recognize I'm self aware when you come
with I'm very competitive let's start
with that and so that's gonna come
through on a speech or in video right
now like yes I want to beat your agency
that's real that's just I'm sorry but I
don't want to do it at your expense
I want anybody who's good to win I
really do I love meritocracy I love
capitalism
I like the market I think it's coming
across well because I'm speaking the
truth meaning in the same way that I'll
be the first person as I am now who's
saying Twitter's broken Twitter's a
problem don't spend money on Twitter
after if I was sitting here 36 months
Twitter would be the only thing out of
my mouth I think that I have enough of a
track record now that people are
starting to realize that what I'm
obsessed with is being historically
correct not where I'm making my money at
the moment yeah like you know I invested
a lot of money into meerkat you haven't
heard a word for me about meerkat for
the last year you know why cuz it's not
gonna win like I'm not pushing agenda
I'm pushing conversation that benefits
us all if marketing was better if media
planning wasn't so broad if all of us
tried to sell more products a lot of us
would do better the industry would be in
a better place and so I want everybody
to win I do I want to build the biggest
building in town yes how do I want to do
that by building the biggest building
not by tearing everybody's building down
so I think what I did in that meeting
was I said look you're acting one way as
a human which means you're not looking
at commercials you're not clicking
banner ads but your marketing all your
money in a different way and you're
doing that because the whole machine is
built on that and I thought it went well
and it was interesting because you know
when you give that talk the first 15
minutes is awkward yeah when you go into
a room and say look I think because
you're not the kind of person normally
they get to see it's relatively
conservative isn't it as a as a
environment you know better than I do
you know I'm just starting to I mean I
think everything's conservative so
probably yeah I mean look look there's
not a lot of people in Madison Avenue
today that had the narrative that I had
which was I first built a 65 million
dollar business on the backbone of what
was considered radical marketing
accommodate a sixth email marketing in
97 Google AdWords the day it started a
YouTube show a couple months after
YouTube came out my career is built on
what I sell so there's not that much
people come up through the world they
become a great account person or a great
creative they team up with a partner and
they start a shop I came from
a different angle and I've got such a
different point of view that it's uh
that it's going well and it's got its
pluses it's got its minuses a lot of
things I wasn't able to come to that I'm
going to the next day in a conference in
a month or so one of the areas that the
na re focusing on as you may or may not
be aware and they've commissioned an
external company to do a an assessment
of the medium potential media rebate
market in the US right there was a guy
who gave a talk at that conference the
previous year of John del Rey who really
caused some ruffles I saw those
headlines yeah that makes sense to me
and the AMA they've created a task force
to look into that and then they've hired
k2 intelligence in New York which is
this let me let me save everybody a lot
of time yeah course that's go like who
doesn't know that that's going on I
don't even know the industry and I knew
that was going on not because I knew
that was going on in this industry it's
what goes on in every industry I come
from the liquor business it goes on
there anytime there's big dollars being
rewarded on a human to human level the
human that's deciding big dollars is
getting rewarded by the human that's
trying to get them in many forms bottles
of Dom P getting their kid into Harvard
taking them to the Super Bowl like what
is like of course it's human beings it's
in human beings now when you've got only
three or four big holding companies that
drive everything it becomes even more
intense so you can see you can see it
obvious as you say like across industry
is the yes business but now you're in
the media business yes up up against
that and if you have we're still small
you know like I mean I think you worry
to policy Oh principal is a hundred
percent there's none of I mean that it
there's I am a meritocracy even at my
own expense the end yeah okay the end if
we're gonna lose a media pitch because
oh the I'll use different letters the
XYZ agency girl takes the decision-maker
to the strip club then I'd rather lose
the business yeah I mean that's that
when you're better you don't have to
play that game well that's good and that
and that's what we that's what I liked
about the narrative
that we were hearing from the agency
when we went to New York I hope you
continue that in Europe that's a
slightly different market is there any
nuance to the European market I mean
there's the cliche stereotypes that you
know the you that I'm to us even for us
so the personality may may rub some
people the wrong way here's here's what
I know look I was born in Eastern Europe
I grew up in the wine business I've
spent an enormous amount of time in
Italy and France and other parts of the
world people are people meaning like I
don't think yes do I think there's some
cultural differences of course but do I
think the decision-maker at Unilever UK
market or Toyota UK market or Nestle UK
market doesn't want to do deep deep down
doesn't want to do the right thing for
their business because maybe it was too
aggressive and that's fine I mean like
I'm they all know it they all I mean
they all really know it if we lose on
something that shouldn't be important
then that's fine by us
so look I think every market marketing
is a tactic to help a transaction happen
we do that extremely well yeah and I
think that um I think that it's gonna go
over extremely well in this market um
I'll tell you what really is most
fascinating to me about the London and
general kind of Western Europe market
there's a stunning lack of respect for
how well modern digital is doing in this
market when you look at the metrics of
Instagram and Facebook and snapchat in
the UK market it's like kind of weirdly
more exciting than the US market yeah I
mean the penetration is at full scale
the behavior is quite aged up I think
there's some real big opportunities I do
I think because the US has so many the
startups start there there's also that
six to 12 month pause you know one is an
incredible market so maybe it's a three
to six month pause but and look I I day
trade so I'm fast in the US having an
extra six or 12 months for a UK market
or a Dublin market or a Berlin market is
really attractive for me yeah
good so finally before you guess the
other thing your legendary 4 is to be is
being a Jets fan mm-hmm we did back in
the beginning of every we did a Super
Bowl special in here and bear in mind
you've met David yes we know nothing
about American football yes and we made
some terribly bad predictions at the
time if you look at the episode of it if
you saw it but we had four Jets sure I
love amaz - thank you thank you thank
you for these prices for this by the way
I had an amazing trip here you know the
Jets played here this last season yes
and Wembley which I had an amazing time
I came best good so we've got so what do
you know about football
European English Premier not just
football American football your stuff
yeah um not that much I mean I watched
the World Cup aggressively I've it's
amazing
the English Premier League has gotten a
lot of play in the US over the last 36
months you know I was I always say that
I was should have never left Europe
because I'm a crazy Jets fan like my
respect level for European football
proper football fans is much hot like I
like that people potentially can die in
the stands like this is something I
respect okay as a fan so what do I know
what do I know I know that um I know
more than I did twenty four months ago
but I don't know a whole lot but I but I
know that a lot of American businessmen
are trying to buy teams I know that uh I
know that a lot more kids are running
around the US with messy jerseys and
things of that nature which I know is
more Spanish stuff and it's not my only
franchise that comes Miami franchise
kicking off I guess yeah my mm-hmm and
uh one of my business partners runs the
Internet the ICC which is a soccer
tournament that has English Premier
League's toward the u.s. so I'm a little
dangerous so we've got to the one thing
I wanted to ask you was just to make
some predictions because we make some
terrible oh good let's do it let's do it
okay so this is there yes our
international game so we don't have
elite games this but we have some
internationals Janet we have a big
rivalry as you probably know between
Germany and England yes of course okay
so a couple of world wars you know no
big deal it's still a lot
should be week so Germany England that's
a touch [ __ ] what yes what do you reckon
Germany in Germany I think I think
Germany will win give me a sec oh ah 2 2
1 2 2 1 ok I'll hold you to that
and I was gonna do kampachi cuz Belarus
if that was enough to say here is that
talk about wanting to be historical that
was harder for me to tell than to tell
an entire room and marketers that
they're all crooks they're all full of
[ __ ]
that was harder to say two to one
Germany I'm sorry
and then the other one else that makes
me sad ask you I'll be rooting for
England and that is not even close by
the way belarus belarus will lose
belarus and everything since it's the
last dictatorship why you all me me
armenia is gonna win six nothing I
reckon only you know Belarus is the last
dictatorship in all of Europe really
unless you want to count Russia I'm for
you yeah
so thank you for that good library best
of luck with the book I think we might
see tomorrow night at the oh they're
gonna be awesome
thank you thanks for having me think it
is Cheers
alright it's gonna be tough to open up a
Russia office after that know everything
do you think okay that's it for this
week thank you for watching please
subscribe to the channel and have a
great weekend great weekend thank you
guys thanks for having me thanks I'll
make sure I share this out get you some
real subscriptions